[Music]
now the george lucas cashed out and
disney turned the franchise into fifa
with lightsabers open wide as they chuck
another hunk of content on the rancor
pit of disney plus
but
this was actually pretty tasty
[Music]
obi-wan kenobi
you had to watch han solo turned into a
broke divorced dad you had to watch luke
skywalker become a gross recluse
now it's obi-wan kenobi's turn to go
down bad and this legend from the
prequels and original trilogy and clone
wars becomes a sad fishmonger who
everyone rose like anakin on beach day
you seem kind of old and beat up the
years have made you weak and the next
nine years are gonna suck even more
prepare for a show that reminds you how
great the prequels were when they're cut
down to a three-minute recap montage and
cheer as the best part of those films
returns
hello dex follow along on the celibate
religious man's new mission
stare at a ten-year-old boy all day
but when a special little princess gets
moved to another castle obi will have to
save a skywalker for the up tenth time
even though he's forgotten his super
speed
forgotten how twins work how old are you
and forgotten how to hide like at all
hey uh you gonna change your last name
buddy maybe dye your hair i don't know
stop wearing jedi robes
that's not an improvement you look like
vincent adult man hello other grown-up
thrill at the latest installment of star
wars babies leia edition vivine blair
shines as a young princess with more
sass than carrie fisher if she were
actually born into royalty if anyone
asks you're my daughter granddaughter
maybe what nothing and once this lone
wolf and cub link up you're in for yet
another round of grumpy warrior gets a
cute sassy kid to safety but hey
if
it
ain't
broke
don't
it hello there again ewing
meet a galaxy's worth of supporting
characters some of whom don't even live
on tatooine
like a guy who puts the mid and
midichlorians so judgmental
an imperial officer who's not like those
other imperials she feels bad about it i
joined up when the empire stood for
something i made some mistakes and evil
twisted villains like modern star wars
fandom if you're sending her bullying
messages you're no star wars fan in my
mind riva a youngling who never finished
her grooming but graduated with honors
from the loud quiet london school of
villainy tell me where the jedi is what
makes you think
he won't see it coming send out the
probes do it nobody's coming
you can't fight obi-wan
and of course darth vader who's now
literally a mix of man and machine
hayden christensen kills it in a dual
role as both the guy in the big d suit
and his anakin in his seventh senior
year at jedi academy he'll give us fresh
insight into vader's loss of humanity
and show us what really turned annie to
the dark side you'll need to prove
yourself as your undoing until you
overcome it a padawan will still be so
to prove himself worthy of being a jedi
anakin had to try his hardest to stop
trying so hard to prove himself worthy
of being a jedi okay this scene makes
sense now
so enjoy the weird new middle ground of
star wars that looks bad for a movie but
good for a tv show too short for a
series but too long for a film
incredible lightsaber duels but rinky
dink sets
and a story constrained by the trilogies
that take place before and after but
drops enough breadcrumbs to launch a
rogue squadron's worth of future star
wars content
just getting started i think i had a
brother i think i've just found out what
they're hiding down here okay none of
those jedi are actually dead disney just
jurassic park them until it's their turn
for a show
starring
gentle ben
problem child that's what i love about
these younglings man i get older they
stay the same age
neon genesis revangelion i don't like
sand snakes they're coarse and rough and
irritating he doesn't even go here
hashtag justice for hat
we only sell moisture here where the
jedi round back
whoops
oh my beiru
what i got i gotta give it to arriva
cool mail none jedi
nice cube
and the one lesson disney can't afford
to learn it's the past move on be done
with it
ben hur
so riva's plan was to work her way up to
grand inquisitor then just try to stab
darth vader in the back
probably gonna see that one coming it's
literally the only way sith get promoted
do you really want to hurt me
do you really want to make me cry
in another life
i would have loved doing laundry and
taxes with you
this time it's going to take more than
killing me to kill me
you